hello why are you all here are there
I've got three stalks and a pub quiz to
do today and I have woken up with the
worst case of impostor syndrome that
I've ever had and I'm just where you
come to listen to me though so yes and
this talk is all about why I'm not
leaving net because I thought that would
make a nice change I'm sure everyone's
read one of those blog posts and various
people's reasons and I just thought I'd
take a look at those reasons and argue
with them and possibly say mean things
about other platforms and languages
while I'm at it because that's always
fun
so we've been doing dotnet but well I've
been doing dotnet programming now for
for 17 years I got the first beta of
c-sharp and the CSC back when you had to
actually edit the code in notepad in the
year 2000 just towards the end of the
year 2000 this was Microsoft in the year
2000 developers developers developers
developers he looks like he'd be more at
home in a Star Trek franchise doesn't he
should be behind the bar in some
horrible alien hovel somewhere but no
Microsoft in 2000 they were kind of the
they were just the big software company
they did everything they were being sued
for antitrust by people who made
different browsers and if you were a
Microsoft developer in the year 2000
then you arrived using C++ or you were
using Visual Basic 6 or
or you were using Visual Basic 6 but
telling everybody you are using C++ like
me because I try to write common
components in C++ as anyone ever tried
to write common components or ActiveX
controls in C++ okay keep your hand up
if you gave up and just went over the BB
six to do it because as seriously calm
in in C++ not easy I interface i unknown
i unknown to because they had to change
the I unknown interface yeah and then at
the end of 2000 they came out with
c-sharp and I downloaded the beta of
c-sharp because they said it's a bit
like Java
it runs on a virtual machine and it's
bytecode and you can run it on any
platform and I went oh yeah I'll be able
to write code for are there other
platforms because in 2000 they really
weren't other platforms nobody was
buying Mac's anymore
UNIX was kind of yeah okay still there
in the banks and that sort of thing it
was a it was a good thing to run Oracle
on at that point but you know so c-sharp
came along I downloaded it and I was
editing code in notepad and it was
actually because of that because I I got
c-sharp I was trying to edit code in
notepad and notepad sucks reading code
and I found out that someone had made a
new version of V I called vim and so I
downloaded vim because I started
programming in 1989 professionally and I
turned up to the first day on the job
and they sat me down and said write this
piece of code and I said what editor do
I use and they said VI and so I VI
filename and then did it and then
started pressing Keys and nothing
happened and I tell someone this but
because these days I install the vim
keyboard shortcuts into anything that I
use and and I said son is my muscle
memory because they were going are you
hipster you hipster for using the using
the vim keyboard shortcuts and I where's
no no seriously because because when I
started in 1990 1989 that VI was the
only thing
I mean our double hipster liked it
before it was cool yeah
fair enough but ya see sharp when they
first one I got that first beat you
couldn't do anything we did it could
like create a single C sharp file there
was no msbuild attached to it or
anything like that and you just did c SC
to build your little console application
the first thing I wrote actually used
reflection to go over all the public
classes and types and methods and
properties in all the assemblies in the
base class library and got myself a big
print out of the entire dotnet framework
so I could start staring at it and just
going oh I wonder what those will do
when I finally get my hands on this and
then when I finally did get my hands on
it when they released visual studio.net
in in 2001 it was windows forms and web
forms and the thing is now we look back
I mean web forms okay that was just a
bad idea I'm not going to say anything
good about web forms it was basically
Microsoft going pretend you're not
writing a web application and will do
all the clever tricks to make it look
like you have written the web
application but it'll be terrible with
viewstate and everything else any web
forms guys in the room yeah still still
like it still sort of no okay good
I was going to get some red cards there
but windows forms actually I don't want
people I don't say mean things about
windows forms because at the time
building desktop applications for
Microsoft Windows was an absolute car
crash Visual Basic 6 was not great and
Visual C++ if you wanted to build a
desktop application you had to actually
code the layout of all your dialogues
and everything else and on the Java side
of things you had swing and various but
they all look like absolute crap and so
when those forms came along and it was
it was amazing you could write Windows
applications that look like Windows
applications that had all the same style
as Microsoft applications and everything
else and so yeah dotnet came along and
it fixed this problem and c-sharp came
along and it was sort of similar to to
C++
made you feel like you were using a
proper grown-up language and not one
where the first letter of it stood for
beginner and and you could yes I'm a
proper programmer and I'm writing proper
code and then they followed that up with
with Windows Mobile
because Microsoft invented the
smartphone yes they did and so you could
do Windows Mobile code and then people
started making new languages that you
could use on on the CLR and you know
because Microsoft said even just
anything can compiled to bytecode so we
had a sharp and boo in the C sharp and
Cobra and component Pascal did anyone
ever use that no obviously and and we
had all the iron languages as well
we had iron Lisp and ironpython oh my
and Ruby and iron scheme iron scheme
still works if you want to write scheme
code you can still write it and run it
using iron scheme on the dynamic
language runtime and then you got
various other languages
I used to use sequel windows that one
down at the bottom there that was gupta
sequel windows in the mid-90s i was
using that to build database
client-server applications and they made
it so that you could take your sequel
windows code and compile it to the CLR
bytecode and so there was all this
exciting stuff and then this popped up F
sharp and you could write funguses
around the time of dotnet 2.0 and I so I
had an argument on Twitter recently
where I said I've tried F sharp and I
don't like it because I was bored that
day and I felt like having a massive
argument with hundreds of people on
Twitter
and it worked but actually it's not true
so I have tried a sharp and I don't
particularly enjoy writing code and a
sharp I don't see why people get so
excited about it but I love a sharp as a
language I absolutely adore it because
anything good that happens in F sharp
will eventually get into C sharp so f
sharp had a sink f sharp had pattern
matching F sharp is the reason that in
dotnet we have proper rarefied generics
so we can create a generic type and then
at runtime using reflection create a
concrete type of that generic type um on
the fly at runtime dynamically is the
word I'm looking for
Java can't do that Java fakes its
generics and if you haven't declared the
thing that compiled sign then it's never
going to happen it's like C sharps
template library but no F sharp angle
and F sharp is good for cert you know
the thing the only thing I don't like
about it is you have to have the files
in the right order in the project that's
the thing that won't smear for F sharp
apart from that fine only whitespace
significant why I don't like significant
whitespace I don't like bugs that you
can't see its no so any shark came along
and then so this was it was kind of
going well but then at some point in the
2000s Linux started to become important
again and people were kind of going all
look the lamps packed Linux and Apache
and my sequel and PHP and web servers
are starting to run Linux all over the
place
and so you're starting to think oh maybe
it would be good if dotnet did work on
Linux but Microsoft weren't going to do
that because Microsoft said open-source
is a cancer and Linux must be destroyed
and will nobody rid me of this turbulent
lineThe and so it looked like we were
never going to get to run net on Linux
and then Miguel de Icaza comes along and
goes I read this Miguel de Icaza is like
one of my top 5 programming heroes this
is a guy who went I really like
I think c-sharp is a great language I
wish I could do C sharp on Linux on the
know you project which is what I do for
a living so I'm going to port the entire
dotnet framework and c-sharp over so it
will run on Linux who does that serious
who goes yes this is just like an entire
division of Microsoft has built this
thing I'm going to re-implement it over
here by myself all right anyone want to
help this is taking longer than I
thought
and you know that motto has always it's
always had its problems and some of the
bits of it don't work as well as other
bits but you could write a complete
asp.net application and run it on mono
on top of the mud apache plugin and
everything else and you could get your
asp.net webforms application working on
a linux box which is just incredibly
impressive and but around this time in
the sort of late 2000s what do you call
them naughties does this know this was
on xkcd the other day there's no word
for the first decade of it or this
decade actually we know the teenys or
something yeah three years time is going
to get so much easier but yes so at
around the same time as as someone loves
dotnet so much that they have ported it
and got it working on Linux you started
to see these blog posts going why I'm
leaving dotnet and it's just kind of
just I I never understood the the points
of these blog posts it's like just go
nobody cares why you're leaving you know
unless you're Anders Hales burg or John
skeet or someone if some ski goes why I
hate c-sharp now then I'll read that
blog post you know but yes people will
go I'm leaving Don and they started out
leaving dotnet to go to Ruby because
because Ruby was like this big new thing
and and actually wasn't particularly
Ruby because Ruby's this language
supposed to make programmers happy
because you can say unless or something
that's I don't know but you know but it
was it was rails and people were going
on building web applications I want to
use the model-view-controller pattern
and like in this rails framework that
we've got over here so I'm going to
build my web application just by typing
console app commands and then I'm going
to put it into production and then I'm
going to go oh no someone's asked for a
feature I'm going to go and try and
implement that feature in a way that
rails developers never thought of which
is when that happens rails is great for
creating crud applications and shipping
them as soon as you want to do something
a little bit different hmm it was
brilliant around 2.3 think is the point
I saw something recently that said in
rails 5 as soon as you create an active
controller it's got something like 160
base classes and mix-ins included in it
that the Ruby runtime has got to load
and compile and get and everything else
before it can actually start serving
your code so yes so there's people going
off to write rails code instead and good
luck to them and fair enough and then
something else came along that made
people suddenly start using something
else and that was this Apple released
the iPhone in 2006 and actually the
original sort of the first year of the
iPhone they said if you want to write
apps for the iPhone right web
applications and just get people to
access them through the browser that's
how you do that thing if I'm like no we
want an SDK and so they released some
SDK and suddenly everybody had to go and
learn objective-c is anyone done
Objective C programming did you enjoy it
who said yes
did you really though it is different
I'll give you that yes I'll tell you how
you make Objective C you take the best
bits of small talk and the best bits of
C++ and you throw them away what you
have left is Objective C and I am
obviously right because Apple has
abandoned it and created Swift instead
and Swift is basically C sharp with a
little bit of Ruby and a little bit of
some other stuff as well but you know
and yes and I don't do that either so if
we were going off doing Objective C and
then people think I'm leaving next I'm
going to go and do Objective C because
I'm going to put my app on the App Store
and make millions of 30 cents times
something whatever and so that was fine
and then nodejs came along and it was
basically saying to people who've been
doing jQuery on the front end you can
write back-end code and lots of people
got very excited about nodejs and NPM
and went off to build applications with
that and I don't know I can't really
fault those people no js' is fine used
to be kind of really really fast doesn't
look quite so fast these days on taking
power but yeah if you like that sort of
thing um the most recent thing that I've
seen people writes
I'm leaving net posts about is go and
yeah so go again I'm kind of conflicted
goes a bit like Python and it's it's got
some good things about it but it is it's
really missing a whole bunch of features
it's very difficult to there's no
generics it's very difficult to do
functional style programming in go
because you can't write a map
function that takes a generic type and
that's kind of important when you're
writing map functions or reduce
functions or all that sort of thing
basically go is what you would get if a
language designer got frozen into a
glass ear in the 1970s and then thawed
out in in the year 2010 and said make a
new programming language without any of
the last 40 years of experience it's
great for writing systems code because
with systems codes you're not
particularly fast about generics and all
this other stuff and you've got kind of
you can do maps over lists of interned
and that sort of thing the big thing
that people always talk about with go is
the fact that it's natively compiled and
and you can just create a single
executable binary and then ship it and
run it on any machine so this is the
only demo in this entire talk but where
am I not you I want a different one so I
have an application here that I have
written in [ __ ] CD down enough
directories so I'm going to open this up
here so here is my dotnet application
this is a dotnet core application with
my program CS file here just a standard
lots of write lines and so forth and I
have added a couple of targets to my CS
prod file so I've got my msbuild SDKs
path so that sort of hooks me up with
the msbuild
pipeline this is dotnet core 2.0 preview
1 and then I've got this import project
here ILC path microsoft.net core native
targets where I got that from was I went
to github
dotnet karate so karate is an
alternative net runtime so it's on an
alternative to the CLR and it's
optimized for ahead of time compilation
so all the libraries to do with
reflection and so forth have being
rewritten and lots the low-level
primitives have been rewritten and
they're optimized so that this can be
compiled to native machine code ahead of
time and if you go to this repository
and go into documentation and go to how
to build and run il compiler in console
shell prompt nd you can read the
instructions here and it's got
instructions for Windows and UNIX and
once you've done that and you set an ILC
path environment variable to point to
the place where you compiled that code
to you can I'm going to just remove my
bin directory so that you can what do
you mean busy
okay so and I'm going to do net build -
see release /t : so this is like an MS
build parameter that's going to get
passed through - MS build link native
okay the warming that you get there is
just that's always going to happen
apparently it's complaining that I've
already imported something because it
was imported in something else but I
imported and so it kind of loops around
on itself and so forth but that has
created if I go into my bin directory
and then into X 64 because that now
becomes important this only works for 64
bits at the moment and then I go into
release and then I go into net core app
- so here I've got my dotnet DLL that I
have compiled because when you compile a
dotnet core executable even if in your
CS profile it says target is an XE it
will create a dll because it has to be
run with the.net command line tool so
it's a bit like mono on Linux you had to
say mono thing you DLL so if I say
dotnet hello RT DLL that runs that code
like that but if I go into native so
just very quickly so you can see here
the hello RT DLL is 11 K so that's my
dotnet application that's byte code to
be loaded into the CLR and run okay but
whoever I send that to has got to have
the dotnet executable to launch that
properly and they have to have don't let
the 2.0 preview one SDK and everything
installed so if I see the interim native
and do dir it's just clear you can see
we have Anna hello RT XE and you can see
that it is 6.1 gigabytes
[Music]
so it's 96.1 megabytes which is quite
big and you might think that's
considering that all that does is this
if I do hello are TXE and then we'll
shrink that down like that you see what
that is
just about it's my Twitter avatar but
yes that is the complete that's the the
runtime and the garbage collector and
everything all bundled in all the
required libraries the system DLL ms
core Lib the whole lot all compiled into
a statically linked native executable
you can take that XE and give it to
anybody running a 64-bit version of
Windows regardless of what they've got
installed and they will be able to run
it okay the really fun thing is I'm not
going to demonstrate this because it's
kind of not particularly visual but I've
got the windows subsystem for Linux
installed on this laptop which is
running Ubuntu effectively and I got the
dotnet Salling for Linux installed and I
went for all the instructions in this
webpage to build and run the il compiler
for Linux and so on my windows box using
the ubuntu bash prompt from the windows
subsystem for limits that I got from the
Windows Store I can go through the same
process with the same code and it
produces a Linux x64 executable that I
can then pick up and give to anybody
running any 64-bit version of Linux and
they'll be able to run it as well for
some reason when I do that a hello world
application is about seven megabytes but
still you know and the point is that
there's two points one it starts up but
there's three points no one expects the
Spanish Inquisition
nice rich uniforms so the first point
people don't need net install they can
just run the executable file and they're
done - it starts up really fast if
you're building a command line tool or a
service that you want to just start up
do something and then shut down again
really quickly the ahead of time compile
there's no cheating involved there's no
loading stuff from all different places
on the disk it just loads runs and exits
really really quickly and the third one
and we're not seeing this just yet but
we will start to see this is the step
between when it produces the il code and
when it produces the native code
currently they're actually using Ryu JIT
they're using the JIT compiler from from
dotnet core to produce the native code
ahead of time but they will be able to
plug in different compilers and they're
working on one that produces C++ code as
a kind of proof of concept but one that
uses the LLVM native compiler and linker
and that will be able to do a lot more
optimization of your code so a JIT
compiler has to do a trade-off between
producing fast machine code and
producing machine code fast ok because
it does want to sit there go what's the
best way to optimize this loop and so
forth whereas if you can say right
you've got like five minutes to do this
build I don't really care how long it
takes you it can produce the most
optimal machine code that you could
possibly have and so this core RT
project is going to end up being able to
do that and with anyone in the David
Fowler and john Galloway's talked last
night about asp net futures roadmap
stuff because one of their targets is to
get asp net core to work with core RT so
you'll be able to write your asp net
core application with controllers and
views and everything else and then
compile it using that dotnet build /t
link native and come out with a single
little executable file that's about ten
megabytes maybe and then put that into
Alpine docker image which is five
megabytes so then you've got a 15
megabyte docker image which is your
complete web application and you'll just
be able to ship that and it'll be
insanely fast because it live being for
an optimizing compiler that's just
produced the best machine code it
possibly could
I'm quite excited about that is anybody
else excited about that
no it's just me I've just bored you
rigid for five minute well never mind it
made me happy and that's the important
thing
so yes and we get all of that with
generics and lambdas and async and await
and and all that cool stuff so yes yeah
to go although I do like defer I have to
say defers nice someone's put deferring
to c-sharp
when I see sharp six I you kind of start
to take it for granted after a while and
then you have to go and write code in in
other languages and you remember all the
stuff that you've got in c-sharp that's
really good because I think a lot of
people are still using c-sharp six
because sevens still quite new and
people are still working with a Visual
Studio 2013 and 2015 and so you but you
know even the c-sharp six you've got
generics which we've had since 2.0
you've got link and lambdas and
extension methods you've got dynamic
does anyone actually use dynamic for
anything
no was yeah any simple t2 people in the
perfect yes sorry about that
we got a sink and await and of started
taking that completely for granted now
and we've got that in typescript as well
now so that's good and these days we
have Roslin so they can add new features
really quickly we've got exception
filters so you can say catch this
exception when something is true so you
can catch an HTTP exception when the
status code is more than 500 or
something and then we got c-sharp 7
which is the kind of current version and
you can start doing stuff with this
we've got algebraic data types in there
we got
pattern-matching on sort of on types but
it's a damn sight better than it used to
be and we've got proper tuples and now
the f-sharp people can thank the c-sharp
people because we've got proper struct
tuples that don't cause allocations
because one of the problems that f-sharp
has always had is that it creates all
these wonderful things but they don't
really get to influence the the
underlying base class library so much so
you get a lot of allocating code you get
a lot of classes instead of straps but
yeah so the lines between fee sharpened
and well these are my predictions the
feesh are eight I think we make the
curly braces optional make the
semicolons optional put in significant
whitespace we just need type providers
and yet we'll have a nice language got a
forum of bone but know this yeah c-sharp
is just brilliant and and these days
2017 the running man I found this out
when I was making this slide deck the
running man the movie was actually set
in 2017 so you know with this ridiculous
dystopian future where an authoritarian
maniac had taken control of the United
States of America you know its 2017 and
a lot has happened in the last 17 years
with with Microsoft Microsoft is now run
by this dude with this little fist BAE
looks like the baby doing the fist bump
doesn't yeah that's that yeah and now
everything's kind of open it's running
on Linux and it's running on Mac and
it's running all over the place
we got new gets package manager the
first time I did this talk I did a
version of this talk a couple of years
ago and this slide said 50,000 packages
and half a billion downloads in the last
two years that's gone to 80,000 packages
80,000 unique packages
not all the different versions of all
the different packages and three billion
downloads from Newgate which is quite
impressive I think people are still
using dotnet you know in those far-off
backward corners of the world but more
importantly than that the entire thing
is now open source and it's on github
and you can go and you can find the the
C sharp compiler Rosling then you can
submit issues and fixes and so forth in
anyone in the room had a pull request
accepted on the Roselyn compiler know
they usually get a handle on or any of
these core CLR core FX any of the ASP
annette core things no just me I fix
documentation that's what I could I get
my name while the contributors list and
all I've done is go there's no
apostrophe there get rid of that there
is no a in exception what are you doing
so yes but yeah it's all it's all there
on github and every everything you know
it's not just dotnet and so it's it's
the entire a spinet core it's the C
sharp compiler it's it's also the editor
so vs code is on github and and it's not
even you know Microsoft in the old days
you are we're doing open source it's the
MS PL license which is our open source
license and the open source people went
that's no no no letting people look at
your code is not open source now it's
all MIT license or it's pretty mad as a
couple of bits that are refractory
because they've got some patterned
things in there and you have to do
Apache if you've got patent things in
there and but the vast majority of it is
MIT licensed which means you can just
take the code and do whatever the hell
you like with it as long as you don't
actually try and compete with Microsoft
or something there's like little
end-user license agreements in there
still so you got that and we've got asp
net core which is just brilliant and if
you've seen the stuff that's coming in
asp net core 2.0 so for the web forms
developers there's razor pages which is
just someone in the team has gone you
know what asp net core one is great but
it doesn't let people do bad things it
doesn't let them mix their markup and
their logic code in the same file in the
way that web forms used to we should
really fix that we should let you put a
function section in CS HTML so yeah
thanks whoever did that but you know
you've got that and then on the other
side the bit that I do like is the fact
that you've got the controller list
method now so it looks a lot like
Express j/s you can just use asp net
routing and you create a Rooter and then
you say map get map put map post map
delete and for micro-services this is
brilliant and it means it's a lot
quicker at runtime than creating a
controller and dis solving all the
dependencies and everything else you
just have a function takes the context
return something back out and get done
so it's very nice and lightweight and
then you look at the stuff that they're
doing for asp net core 2.1 and they've
got amazing things happening to kestrel
you've got all the pipeline stuff you've
got running over native sockets you've
got running on windows r io this is so
this is one of the reasons why I'm not
leaving dotnet is the people who are
currently steaming dotnet forward are
just pathological about it they love
what they're doing and they are
obsessive about getting the best
performance out of it you know in the
Year in 2009 if you'd gone to people in
Microsoft and said why is asp.net like
literally at the bottom of the tech
empower benchmark they would have gone
what's the tech empower benchmark but
now they kind of they got themselves up
to 10th place on the tech empower
benchmark and then in round 14 they got
knocked down a bit because like half a
dozen new frameworks came out that were
written in raw C++ or rust or something
and were faster and but they're
determined to get back up there again
and they're kind of
creating utf-8 strings so that they can
do just read your HTTP header directly
off the network card and pass it there
and then write the response directly
back to the network card and it's it's
awesome it's just this insane passionate
bunch of people trying to make the best
fastest nicest framework that they
possibly can in a language that we all
know and and enjoy using I think that's
brilliant I'm working on something on
the side that there's a some of the
taking power benchmarks are pulling data
after the database and serializing it to
Jason and when you do that at the moment
in net you basically go to the database
and say give me the thing back now pull
the data out of there into an object and
then use JSON net serialize that object
to bytes and then send that back down
the HTTP response which is it's the
dotnet way of doing things and it's fine
but it puts us quite a long way down on
those benchmarks on taking power and so
I'm wondering what happens if we get our
sequel data reader and read the values
of it and write them directly to the
HTTP response as Jason without that
intermediate step of creating an object
and then serializing it back out again
so that's that's what I'm doing
hopefully that's going to push this back
up there again so that's that could be
fun but asp net court you can run it on
linux and which is quite handy i had an
application it's shut down now because
it was tooling for the microsoft
technology and so of course they made
their own version of it what the hell is
happening with my timer
that's okay sorry my timer says always
because I stopped and did the demo and
then restarted that's okay yes sorry
I've got a pair of white prison
presenters for you talking about yes I
had an application that was running in
every issue a data center in the world
and it was running on asp net MBC and
web api and it was running on Azure app
services and it was costing me a bloody
fortune to run it and then I just
migrated it over really easily to a
everything's version or point five of
asp net five and started running it on
Linux boxes in every day centre in the
world and my hosting costs halved
because Linux is free and so you know
and then add in the fact that you've
gone from a framework that can serve
like 10,000 requests a second or the
framework but can serve a million
requests a second and you can probably
shut down like 90% of your servers as
well and still get the same performance
so that's good that's nice you can run
it in docker so you can spin yourself up
a docker clustering kubernetes or swarm
or whatever else and create docker
containers if you want to see a bit more
about that come to my next talk in ring
5 brave new net where I'll be showing
some of the stuff that you can do with
all this these new bits and pieces I'm
going to encourage you to do that I
think by finishing this talk over it
looks like we'll see um if you are for a
long time not anymore because this is a
brand new razor blade paint lovely hi so
nice which I bought because it can do
well jar can plug an oculus rift headset
into it
I still haven't actually bought the
oculus rift headset because I'm trying
to work out how to explain that to my
wife I need it for work you work for a
bank
ok but yes for until March this year I
was he had this beat-up old laptop and
it really wouldn't run everything I
needed it to run on Windows so I was
running Linux as my primary operating
system and I have Visual Studio code and
it worked pretty nicely and I had
JetBrains Rider for a while as well
jetbrains rider is coming
and amazingly it's really really good if
you're doing web stuff by the way and
I'm not getting paid to say this but if
you're doing web stuff so if you're
doing an application which is asp net
core on the back end and angular or
react on the front end then ryder is
essentially like having visual studio
with resharper and webstorm all in one
IDE it's amazing so yes go and take a
look on the on the stand outside but yet
vs codes got intellisense and
refactoring and everything else and
again come to the brave new net I'll
show you a trick with the refactoring
that you might not know about that
that's all powered by omni sharp which
you can also plug in to vim and Emacs
and Adam if for some reason you want to
use an electron based editor and you
don't want it to be vs code because you
want something that's actually going to
make your fans spin up because it makes
you feel alive I don't know there are
some weird people out there but that's
all powered by omni sharp which is open
source and an on github and you can
contribute to that and create borrow it
and create your own version that works
with your favorite text editor it still
supports to be line which I find just
bizarre but yes we are we are basically
living in the future at this point and
we've we can write c-sharp code we can
pick up our C sharp skills and we can go
and use them absolutely anywhere
thanks to xamarin and xamarin forms and
you know this is now bundled with Visual
Studio this is Microsoft own this and so
you can create applications for iPhones
and iPads and Android phones and Android
tablets and OS X and Windows 10 you WP
and and everything else using exam or
Institute of Visual Studio from Mac as
it's called now and Visual Studio and
you can build a write the application
logic once if you use Ameren forms you
can kind of get away with just writing
your your layout once if it's a fairly
simple application then we'll standard
which they're working on is going to
make it so that what xamarin calls a
label and what uwp calls a label and
what WPF calls a label is all the same
thing instead of you having to remember
that it's a label over here and a text
span over here and a text block over
here so that's going to be awesome but
yeah and you can even it's only at the
point where you actually need to publish
the application into the Apple App Store
now that you actually need a Mac to
build your package to send to the App
Store with the new live coding stuff
that they show the build you can just
have a Windows PC and be developing and
debugging against a Mac and it goes
through some kind of weird live cloud
build I don't know what's going on there
it's witchcraft but yes you can and so
you can ship to all those different
things because you know Windows desktop
stuff is becoming increasingly
marginalized for most people and then
there's unity3d has anyone played with
unity at all yeah so as I was hoping to
do a demo but I couldn't get it to work
because I kind of sucked but at home
with my 11 year old daughter I am
writing a game in unity it kind of
inspired my doodle jump you're bouncing
up the tower basically but yeah and I'm
teaching her C sharp and she's going
Debbie why why is there a semicolon at
the end of this line and not a semicolon
on the end of that line and I'm kind of
going oh yeah that's not very intuitive
is it maybe we should use F sharp yeah
but yeah so Kerbal space program which
is this thing that's on on the screen
here that was written in unity stardew
valley the kind of weird harvest moon
farming game that was written in unity
there is a whole ton of games out there
that were written in unity with c-sharp
and it is it's bonkers and you kind of
go edit this script and visual studio
2015 pops up and you're kind of editing
and then you can start it and step debug
it and so forth and the ball hits the
thing and bounces and I get a breakpoint
and the thing just freezes and I'm
coming over on this screen over here
going why isn't my physics working it's
amazing and it's C sharp and you just
same thing that I'm using all day and I
can use it in the evening as well with
unity I can write a game and
I'll get windows and mac and linux and
xbox Xbox one Xbox one s Xbox one X
PlayStation 4 PlayStation 4 Pro the
switch they're working on getting it
running on the switch the tablets and so
forth I can write VR games to run oculus
rift and vivre and you can even target
hololens and hololens
you've also got just the fact that
Microsoft with UWP hololens is now just
another one of the targets that you can
create a Windows application for so just
out of the box when you create a uwp
application one of the ways to publish
it will be so that it's a big floating
rectangle in the middle of space and I
mean seriously this is we are looking in
the future this is amazing there's a
hololens out there and the in meta stand
have got a hololens which i'm assuming
they're not just showing to go and look
we've got this no you can't use it so go
and pretend to be interested in whatever
it is they're selling and and see if
they'll let you have a go because i had
a go on a holiday these bonkers
it is just it's not the fact that the
thing appears there because you're going
to like yeah ok that's fair enough it's
that when you move your head the thing
stays rock-solid where it is it's and
you know at the moment hololens is this
kind of only works indoors and it's
quite a big heavy thing and so forth but
in like 10-15 years time if I'm back
here again in another 17 years right I
would be very surprised if we're still
doing it in this way because I'm just
going to be able to put on something
like a pair of oh please like you wear
for cycling or running or something and
get the full hololens experience and I
already know what application I'm going
to write when that comes along it's
going to be go to Google Maps and it
sound going for a run and you draw out
your route that you're going to run and
then you go out and you start running
and it puts coins all the way along your
route
and and every kilometer there's like a
big coin or a big piece of fruit or
something and then I'm going to have
in-app purchases so that Sonic the
Hedgehog fans can change the coins for
gold rings and pac-man fans can change
them just to like pill shapes and when
you turn around this for colored ghosts
chasing you but here this is just mixed
reality thing is going to completely
change we're going to have no there'll
be no monitors on desk speakers you'll
just put your thing on it'll make it
look like there's three massive monitors
so we got that coming along we've got
the Internet of Things you can take you
this Windows IOT core now yeah see you I
did that it's clever but yes you got
Windows IOT core so you can take it's
like windows and install it on the
Raspberry Pi I've got a Raspberry Pi at
home that's running Windows just so I
can run iTunes on it so that I can use
it it's if that will tv basically I used
I've got iTunes in store and it's not on
that's not on the Play that's on the
Intel Edison board that I got which is a
x86 thing hundred quid really really
cheap but yes you can you can take your
donate core code the the ahead of time
compilation thing that I demonstrated
with karati
you're going to be able to do that to
create arm binaries and so then you'll
be able to just take your tiny little
thing and stick it on a Raspberry Pi
zero and attach it to runes or whatever
it is you do with the internet of things
I don't know create light bulbs that can
be hacked by botnets and used to bring
down the the United Kingdom and and make
it look like we voted for bricks it
so anyway the Raspberry Pi in summary
then over the last 17 years of dotnet I
don't think anyone can deny that
Microsoft have done have made a few
mistakes yeah they've cocked up a couple
of times which has made a bunch of
people very happy very unhappy and has
caused people i leaving dotnet forever
shutting down silverlight caused a whole
mass exodus go my guys but it's like
browser plugins have become redundant
and we don't need them anymore so we're
not going to make it and the whole bunch
people went but we liked browser
pleasure and they all went off like that
and so yes and people have left and
they've gone to rails and they've gone
to mode and all this other stuff but
there's a lot of people who are still
now you kind of go oh look dotnet it's
got this now we've got dotnet cornell we
couldn't cross platform now it's run
analytics now and they're just people on
twitter kind of slagging you off and
going why are you still doing dotnet why
don't you just move on just donate on
the scrappy it's not on the scrappy okay
dotnet has had a difficult sort of
teenage years but it's just now getting
into adulthood it's just getting warmed
up and i think it is an amazing platform
i am going to continue to use it to
build as many different things as i can
think of and i hope that i will be back
here in 2030 with augmented reality so
that my goggles can make you all look
like cartoon characters from looney
tunes and talking about what we're going
to be doing with dotnet over the next 15
years thanks very much
[Applause]